foreign
yes I got a fast one for you alrighty
this one is going to be about Wheels I'm
gonna say uh I'll say a bit pedestrian
for you
just okay
would it be any more pedestrian than
water tower oh good point only our web
viral still the most popular one of
these that we've done I think would have
never thought that one would have landed
the way a couple couple million people
were just like water towers man God
so maybe the wheels will do the same
thing you ready okay did you know
that if you're driving down the road
pick a speed 60 miles an hour nah that
ain't me okay whatever you gotta bump
that up by about 25 miles and now we
talking
at whatever speed you're going okay
there is a part of your car all right
that is going forward at zero miles per
hour at all times all right this already
got interesting because I okay I have no
idea what you're talking about right now
there's another part of your car okay
that's going forward at twice that speed
at every moment oh God okay
Jesus okay
um all right okay so okay you ready okay
are you seated okay here we go hey here
we go okay it's all happening in your
wheels
so the part of the wheel at any moment
contact with the pavement is not moving
at all that's right damn it's no if your
car was skidding right then the part of
the wheel in contact with the road would
be moving forward would be moving
forward at the rate you're skidding
forward but that's why you're moving
forward it's it's why you're moving
forward
because part of the wheel is not moving
at all absolutely because if it were
you'd be spinning in place you'd be
spinning in place correct by the way
okay now you know what man you did it
again
[Music]
to say
I know I I gotta say I now I'm first of
all this is what I'm gonna do right now
I'm a publicly apologize to you for all
that I was thinking
because now before I begin let me tell
you something I was thinking some stuff
I'm apologizing to you right now because
you were like all right Chuck we're
gonna talk about Wheels I'm like this
rather than lost his damn mind we gonna
talk about Wheels seriously you did it
go ahead let's all right let's go for it
let's keep going let's keep going so the
center of the wheel right
which is
it's spinning but the exact center is
going forward at the same speed the car
is absolutely the top of the wheel is
going forward at twice the speed of the
car that's the speed of the car just
like twice the speed right wow okay
because notice if the chassis of the car
is moving at the speed of the car
obviously the top of the wheel is moving
faster than the chassis right okay
it's moving past the chat the top of the
wheel well the wheel well the top of the
wheel well is going forward at your
speed at your speedometer speed the top
of the wheel is going faster than that
to come around to the bottom so that
it's not moving at all and feed that if
you run the math on that you get you get
zero at the bottom the speed of the car
in the middle of the wheel and twice the
speed of the car at the top of the wheel
and so this is this is the geometry the
math and the physics
of a of an axled wheel on any moving
vehicle
what are you doing
Chuck and smoking something I'm just
saying I'm ready to talk about this all
day
I can smoke him okay
but wait there's more that's awesome
that is awesome but wait and this person
on the wheel as and a DOT at the chassis
and then it comes it has to go faster
than that faster it has to go faster so
it could come in the top of the wheel
well that's right so it can come around
correct so now now think of the wheel
that's on a train there's the metal flat
part that touches the the metal rails
but then there's another part it's like
a coupler there's an outer part that
extends outside of the track can you
picture this it's not just rolling on a
track it's like a lip like a lip on the
table itself a lip that extends outside
of the track which enables the train to
stay on the tracks otherwise we'll just
drive off right so these lips that are
exterior to the wheels keep the train
aligned on the track right but here's
what's interesting
they dip
below
the contact point of the wheel and the
rail correct
that by a little bit but whatever it is
they dip below well if the top of your
wheel is going twice the speed
the center of the wheel is going the
speed the bottom of the wheel is going
zero anything lower than the bottom of
the wheel is moving backwards oh snaps
that's right okay okay
going in reverse it's going
reverse so for any train there are parts
of that train that are moving backwards
on the track at all times that's that's
pretty wild just picture that you know
there's the wheel rolling the part
that's below the contact point is moving
backward it actually lands in a place
behind where it started right that means
it moved backwards that's right that's
insane
that's so I just thought I'd put that
out there I know it's not nothing deeper
than that the next time I tie up a woman
and put her on the tracks I'ma let her
know that this you're gonna learn
something
this is what you do Chuck okay I said
twirl my mustache now here's something
interesting are you ready so that means
there's a part of your car that's going
at all speeds
from zero up to twice the speed of the
car correct that's right okay
so imagine this
imagine attaching some device to your
wheel
that sends out a microwave signal and
you can adjust it up or down okay from
the center of the wheel to the outer rim
and sends out or from the center of the
wheel to the bottom so she sends out a
microwave signal
that will report a speed of your car at
any speed you choose
so the police officers there with the
radar gun with the return signal
that's going 30 miles an hour even
though you're going 60. they'll get the
reflected signal off of your car right
but if you can override that with a more
powerful signal sent from your wheels
you can broadcast any speed you choose
down to zero if it's attached to the
wheel right that's the speed I'm
choosing by the way
we can't do zero because they know
you're lying well
any place between the center of the
wheel and the bottom bottom of the wheel
it will you can broadcast the speed
of that Spinning Wheel at any speed less
than your actual driving speed to
configure this would be really weird and
how to make that happen because it has
to be moving with the tire I don't know
how you would design the engineering of
that but it's just something to think
about because there's always a part of
your car that's going everywhere from
the speed of your car down to zero and
up to twice the speed of the car well
maybe you know when the cop pulls you
over you can just tell him I don't know
what speed you recorded but uh it I
don't know you should have been looking
at the bottom of my wheels
yeah that'll work in court
so that's all I have to say about wheels
that was um pretty damn good I mean
sorry part of my language that was
pretty dogling good uh now there's a
completely surprised taking taken aback
by this one
yeah and there's another kind of wheel
which is the shape of the object that
rotates within a Wankel engine
so if you imagine an equilateral
triangle but curve the corners of it and
make the sides a little bit convex right
so it's a triangle I had a Mazda once oh
you did was it with a wanko engine okay
so so that shape interestingly
the distance from the bottom to the top
right Remains the Same no matter how
it's oriented
so if you roll it along the uh if you I
made one of these shapes in fact I don't
have one with me here we might have to
do another explainer we used to call
them spirographs when I was a kid okay
yeah so they're related they're related
geometry to it so if you take a plank
and place it on top of one of these
triangular shapes and roll it the plank
will be absolutely steady even though it
looks like the thing is bobbing up and
down it's because there's no Central
axle to it right
okay we think a wheel needs a wheel that
gives you a smooth ride needs one
Central axle because the wheel is the
same distance to each point on the rim
you can design a shape where the top is
always the same distance from the bottom
even though the center is moving in your
spirographian sort of way nice so I
actually built one of these when I was a
kid in wood shop in seventh grade and I
don't think it's with me here that is in
a closet somewhere I'm gonna have to dig
it up and we'll do another one just fun
things to do with with a wanko engine
nice yeah it's an unfortunate name but
yeah
I know right it's a little weird it is a
little weird but it's one of the many
engines that have been developed over
the years to convert chemical energy
into kinetic energy I know we'll do an
explainer just on engines in the history
of engines oh that's a great one why
they differ from each other and where
they're headed that that's a good one
and now you know that part of your car
it ain't moving at all but don't use
that as the excuse when you get pulled
over
that's it or don't experiment with how
the cop will react if you give that as
an excuse right if you don't want it
all right Chuck we got to call it quits
there all right it's been another
explainer this one just on Wheels in
case you never knew uh Chuck always good
to have you there always a pleasure you
know the grass Tyson here four stars
foreign
[Music]